Dave what's the number one mistake
people make with their money as if
there's like credit card or crypto or
there's one stupid thing that's more
stupid than the other stupid things and
it's not the number one mistake people
make with their money is they don't pay
attention they're not
intentional no one becomes successful at
anything no one wins at anything unless
it's a series of intentional acts no one
accidentally has a great marriage no one
accidentally has a great career no one
accidentally wins the World Series no
one accidentally wins it's a series of
intentional acts now why would you take
these intentional acts that are painful
usually because there's a price to be
paid to win we know that we do it
because we believe they're going to work
when you believe they're going to work
that's called hope